what was what was the first claim you
made where the first first one where
people are like oh [__] this guy's up to
something what that was kind of weird
what's he talking about what's the first
thing you said that became a reality
that at first everybody thought you on
it
because we have this one if you can play
this one here this is July 25th of 2001.
okay and whose family builds all the
military
go back there you go I threat like a Bin
Laden who was a known CIS shot in the
80s running the mujahideen war and whose
family builds all the military bases
over in Saudi Arabia right now assistant
the board of iridium satellite
he's the boogeyman they need and the
sorwellian phony system
a big part of the solution after you
research all the government terrorism
and check out what I'm saying is true
call the White House and tell them we
know the government's planning terrorism
we know Oklahoma City and World Trade
Center was terrorism we know the joint
she's a staff wanted to blow up
airliners Baltimore Sun if you do it
we're going to blame you because we know
who's up to it or if you let some
terrorist group through it like the
World Trade Center we know who to blame
and if there was an outside threat like
a Bin Laden who was a known CIA asset in
the 80s
so you you say this
free it going National and by the way I
did a two and a half hour show that
will only have that clip it's in one of
them to find and re-uploaded the web
because when they took mine on my
YouTube it all got erased that's a copy
of a copy of copy I did two and a half
hours specifically saying they're gonna
blow up the World Trade Center call the
White House tell them don't blow up the
World Trade Center so I'll I'll find
that full clip this week because it
needs to go up and I'll put it back up
yeah and by the way we have your
permission to use your Clips anything
you want it's all free to hear so okay
so when you did that what what is the
reaction from that to 910 like pre we're
like what are you talking about that
this is going to be happening you you
must be losing your mind like what was
the reaction people gave when you first
said that well it's funny I mean I
already had a local radio show in in um
2001 and I was I've been fired off local
radio so I was doing it out of my house
but it was actually on satellite and on
probably 100 stations by then but but uh
I this is pre-youtube so if I wanted to
be on TV I'd use the studios a little
access station so that's a two and a
half hour live show I did uh one night
uh you know a few months before 9 11.
and what was the question
no what I'm trying to say is between
this when you make that claim I'm free
911 during that two-month period what's
the reaction from people to you and then
right after 9 11 happens what do people
say about you sure what happens I was
kind of going back in my memory and then
trying to find exactly that's why I was
just kind of tracing back to the point
because then once I remember one thing I
remember the rest
um this is a crazy story
okay
so I would do live shows once a week
there but we turn a tape in that they'd
are like 10 more times on average so I
shot this live turn the tape in at
Access TV and on night of 9 11 the two
and a half hour show aired and I got
death threats or anything else because
they thought I was saying that day that
the government had done it when I was
saying July 25th but but later you know
the date came out people figured it out
so people were completely freaked out uh
they didn't know what was going on
um a little bit after this happened they
sent some FBI agents you know in like
it's plain clothes to the access station
when I was there trying to talk to me
and stuff and ask asking me questions
and hey we know about terrorists do you
know anything about like you know teams
or teams of people and I'm thinking oh
you're an FBI agent I don't know what
you mean teams they were trying to imply
like I had Terror teams or something I
guess this struck a nerve so they sent
in a couple FBI agents uh but and I was
on my radio show we ought to find the
archives of that saying they're going to
do it because I could see the
pre-programming
where they're saying terrorists are
about to hit and when the terrorists hit
you've got to give up all your rights
and we're gonna have to have trips on
the streets and blah blah blah and I saw
a couple of globalists uh Gary Hart and
one other guy on uh
uh CNN and this is right throwing on
there and did this and they and they
were basically saying life's about to
change the world's about to be
completely different
we're gonna have to take your rights
away terrorists are about to hit and I
saw articles in the local paper saying
that I saw the pre-programming like a
rollout was happening and I knew that
islamists had hit the towers
in 1992 it was a real attack but the FBI
had cooked the bomb allowed him to do it
protected him blocked Ahmad Salam the
Egyptian uh is this proven is this it
all came out yeah and I read interview
pull that up go ahead keep going type in
Ahmad Salam uh uh recordings World Trade
Center bombing
press conference where he recorded the
FBI tell him no we're gonna let the
bombing go ahead because he thought they
were trying to set him up and then and
it did go forward Society knew about
this had a lot of data and a lot of
information
feeding into I thought they would go
back and try to bring down the World
Trade Center a second time because in
criminology that's what happens and they
did have people on airplanes and they
were islamists but it turns out they
were CIA with double passports and we're
being protected and they thought they
were taking part in a hijacking drill
that day and then what really happened
is they nerve gassed the people on the
planes from the best info we have then
remote control them into the towers and
then another one was supposed to hit the
Pentagon uh but uh uh people despite the
fact that they have the stewardess
recordings where they're saying I can't
breathe I can't breathe there's gas
that's what's really happening again but
before they could do that uh a F-16 uh
put and that's in the FAA recordings put
two aim nines into it and shot it down
over Pennsylvania
yeah I was in the United States Air
Force while all that was happening and I
was on the on the on a shooting team and
two days before the competition one of
my sergeants and I'm not going to say
his name was like hey well Shawna
because I was the best shooter Alex he's
like the competition's canceled and I
was like what are you hot why 911
happens and then we were warned rumsell
went on one in front of the White House
and he was like Uh something's happening
where terrorism he kind of warned us
Condoleezza Rice warned the mayor of was
it Chicago don't fly to New York this
day and then you nailed it out when you
were talking about Osama Bin Laden every
flight in the entire United States was
grounded there was a couple f-16s
circling the only commercial flights
that were left from here flew to
Ramstein Germany and it was Osama bin
Laden's entire family they flew them all
out that was on local Miami News they
flown
but it gets worse what I'm saying
there's thousands of pieces of data
they didn't find one they found two
hijackers passports unburned in that
whole explosion so you got 10 feet of
dust everywhere billions of papers but
those get found the next day believe
that so so and it goes on for days
but I interviewed
the former chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff right before he died about this
and a bunch of other people and they
they told me before it came out a few
years later that all the top generals
were supposed to go to New York that day
for a big meeting they got told not to
go and remember
um uh the the Pentagon asked infant
guard leaders a month for about two
weeks before he pulls up articles that's
all that corporate Executives you know
get get approached be part of Homeland
Security before they announced that name
and infrastructure protection and the
whole Shadow government program they
flew him to Offutt Air Force Base
um was that the one that just remember
it's just ancient history they flew them
all to an Air Force Base and had them in
a hangar when the attack was happening
and closed the doors and gave him some
secret briefing look up uh uh Business
Leaders billionaires flown to Air Force
Base the 911 it's it's all up there and
this is such ancient history having gone
over this in years I should write a book
on 9 11 and go back over it all I mean
it is just insane so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]